I was like you I decided to be cool to
hang out with some of the tough kids
you know who I'm talking about they were
hanging on the streets late at night
more than cigarette smokers homes and
then
one day
that's it
now I know this plan is foolproof check
this out
first of all you and me start working at
the bank doesn't matter the position
okay just so long as we get in there all
right then we just go there every day do
the work gain that trust until we get
them in the palm of our hand
all right
that's how we get the money that's the
beauty of it bro
they deposit the money into our bank
accounts week after week month after
month they're not even gonna know they
being robbed and then 20 or 30 years
later
we walk out the front door
nothing even happened
mother that's called a job
what are you doing come on I'm coming
stay where you are what are you doing
thank you
you're not unlocking it we are doing it
at the same time as the problem nope
nothing happens if you're holding it up
everybody knows not to do that because
now it's salt and sugar in the middle
you gotta look down in the middle now
stop take your hand away from the door
completely thank you
what happened what happened though what
happened I don't know what happened
please no no no
[Music]
wait what what's the joke what
I don't get it you shot that damn fool
oh oh yeah no I still don't get it hey
man ain't nothing again
this [ __ ] is just funny man
do can't snitch now
no fake laugh
huh that's not real
I could tell
oh I think it's really funny no you
don't
look at them sitting there all dead
he was 20 and now he's dead
ain't never gonna have a wife for kids
now what are you doing Wife and Kids
that [ __ ] ain't funny
his mom and dad ain't never gonna see
him again no
no
you ruining it for me okay well I guess
I just don't get it there it's just that
you shot him that's all that's the whole
thing oh okay so
oh
what the hell is wrong with you you
don't shoot a dude that's already dead
that's not funny oh
yeah yeah I guess I just don't get it
it's life sentence
in order to survive he must join a gang
you understand I know how it worked
right when you're in prison what you
need is protection rights and the way to
do that is by getting into a game
[Music]
I was surprised to find out that there
is a ball gang in prison they gonna be
my homies talking about some bbww
what's up homie
nice haircut
get the [ __ ] out of here they I mean
they haven't officially asked me to be
in the game yet because you need to earn
their respect first
hey
you're in the wrong neighborhood
black mother
[Music]
step on my homies
bald Brotherhood job yeah bye
Brotherhood what's up what's up you know
what I'm talking about
but that was it right there okay that's
what they call it jumping that's the
initiation process so it's my
understanding that I am now a member of
the ball Brotherhood gang okay
I mean those mother
beat it at me that's a euphemism you
hear all the time but you don't know if
it's true it can't be true how is it
possible but that [ __ ] it's
diarrhea
right out my ass
so I hope like I hope that's like
lifetime dudes right there
it's the happiest day of my life is what
I'm saying despite the lack of
encouragement Lewis continues to try and
ingratiate himself to the gang what this
is the [ __ ]
yeah that's what I'm talking about here
bro trying to creep up on my board
Brothers [ __ ] ought to kick you again
[Applause]
oh I mean I think I I accidentally got
hit by some of my bald Brothers
[Applause]
hood forever man sup
but sure that's prison man I mean you
don't never know what side is coming
from Lewis has yet to make any alliances
meanwhile an unprecedented peace has
been broken between black and white
prison gangs the one since a mountable
racial divide now bridged by a mutual
hatred foreign
[Music]
okay students settle down
settle down
that includes you Mr Rodriguez do you
want to take the milk carton off of your
head
thank you so much
we have a special guest today
he's from this neighborhood
and he's a former gang member
and he's coming here this morning
to talk to you about life choices
so please give a warm Central High
School welcome to Donnie Herrera
[Applause]
I used to be just like you
just like you you you you
used to clown around
make fun of the principle
put milk on my head just like you
Rodriguez
and then
I got hit with AIDS
consequences
[Music]
got into some real trouble oh boy
[Music]
stole from my mom and dad
stole from my own sister and then one
day
a piano fell on my head what
consequences
I feel like you missed a step there step
there gave me 88 concussions one for
each key you think I'm learning but no
see I'm just like you I got back out
there started making some real crimes
home boy
oh yeah
oh yeah
and then
I got trampled by a herd of buffalo what
consequences okay Danny um I think we've
had enough done with my story
I was like you I decided to be cool to
hang out with some of the tough kids
you know who I'm talking about they were
hanging on the streets late at night
more than cigarette smokers homes and
then
one day
I got shot out of a catapult that's it
okay into the mouth of a dragon students
everything you've heard here today is a
lie I don't lie anymore you're all
excused
look at me
I shouldn't even be here
so I got really deep in the crimes I did
a drive-by at my own daughter's
quinceanera
yeah shut up everybody dead killed
yeah
yeah then I got sucked into a wormhole
consequences that's it okay everybody go
I was in another dimension tried to
introduce my own parents to each other
almost failed Aaron was disappearing I
invented Johnny Be Good at my parents
prom and at the last moment they kissed
and they came back the faster we get
away from them the better so nobody
believe me with my graduate my grad
oh
[Music]